Where should I start or what should I first concentrate out if I'm feeling overwhelmed we get this question a lot from people
When they start because you do feel like you're drinking from a fire holes, and I get it
We don't want you to feel that way. So number one if you feel that way just call us and talk to us
But where do you start? Well start with using your right machine
So if all you did was use your right machine you'd be way ahead of the game. So
I have patients and I probably said this to most people on their case review
I've had patients over the decades that
Literally came to me and they're typically men that said I ain't gonna change my diet
I could take those supplements, but I'll use that machine. Okay, and they got better. So I
I think that is the biggest key to you improving is using your right machine. So it's not a magic wand
But that's the that's the most important thing. I can't tell you how many times that we have
Had people not to eat well and we then we talked about the phone and they haven't used the right machine for months
Okay, so it's not gonna help you by not using it. So you got to be using that
Number two if you already have your binder your new start here. You already are your binder start going through it really slowly. It is follow the
You know follow what you're supposed to take with your supplements and you die and it's not that difficult
You don't need to watch any videos. You don't need to study the members side
You don't need to learn you don't need to become a practitioner, okay?
So some people they feel like that's what they're calling is that God had them get this disease so that they could learn as much as they could to help others
Well, that's good, but you got to make sure that that's what you're called to do if you're feeling overwhelmed
It's probably because you're doing
Things you shouldn't do you need to just rest in the Lord you need to take a step back and go okay
I'm trying to do things in my own strengths and
That's why I feel overwhelmed at least that's what I can say from my experience
I was trying to get a knife machine connected today and it would not connect and it was extremely overwhelming for me
Because you know, I'm not a young you know
Chick try, you know have learned computers when I was a kid either so, you know, I this I'm not extremely
Technologically, you know apt
So it was very frustrating and
Round and round and then here was just a chip in the machine that I had to have to actually get changed
So I kid it you can get overwhelmed, but when you're out of your
When you're out of what God is called you to do that's the biggest reason why you get overwhelmed
So sometimes you just need to take step back and rest in the Lord and just do the things that you know to do go one step at a time
Um a call us but we'll help help call you down. We'll get you back out of the straight there
I don't think in general it makes me sad when people don't use us
I feel like God has called us to this and I would the answer this question for Marie as well
She's here not because I'm here so well
She's here because she believes this is a calling for her and she loves you guys
And she wants nothing more than to
Help you and
Council you and encourage you and I know you guys have all said to me that that's what you feel like on the phone or even calling and try to order
Supplements from Megan and you're so encouraged because she's such a delight to speak to
Um, that's what we want to be for you. It makes me sad when we don't hear from people for you know a long long time
And I get it. We're not trying to create codependency here
But we also want to be here for you. So it makes me sad when we don't hear from somebody in a long time and they really should have called us
Um, so don't don't do that. So you're not putting us out by contacting us